guys think that if a girl is a single
mother that the man and the women are
equally responsible
what do you mean
so if a woman's a single mother who's
responsible the man or the woman
as in parents and they're both
responsible they're equally for an
unplanned pregnancy would you say
okay but sorry I'm going to rephrase the
question I didn't ask you right who's
more responsible for an unplanned
pregnancy the man or the woman both
equal 50 50. okay what do you think 50
50. no it's the woman's responsibility
is her responsibility to protect herself
and be on the pill or any form of
contraception she knows her body and I
didn't say so it's not 50 50 it's 100
woman's responsibility not all women can
take contraception
condoms
yeah that's the man's responsibility no
no it's nice I mean to put it on yeah we
have an unprotected sex and if there's a
possibility she could get pregnant how
many women put on condoms come on
nothing
no I mean put condoms on men
you want to make sure it fits properly
put it on yourself why women looking at
that you'll get a dick in your hand
you'll suck a dick but you won't put a
condom on please
now you learn how to put a condom on
yourself you never learned that a
cucumber put it on yourself
squeeze the tip get all the air out put
it on yourself then you know it's on
properly so no I think that women should
carry condoms just as much as men men
put them on women put them on because at
the end of the day it's your dick put it
on
you agree with that
yeah I do agree with that yeah so you
change your mind
I don't think there's still two people
having sex though do you think they have
equal amounts of choice
in regards to getting pregnant no in
regards to contraception
so like for example I as a woman you can
track when you're ovulating the men
can't do that
the women we can be on the pill and we
can lie to them hypothetically about the
pill they can't do that they could stop
holding a condom so could we yeah so
that's what I mean all right but that
one's 50 50. right so he could stab
holes we could stab holes but when it
comes to the birth control
they have no male contraception they
can't track when we're ovulating if
you're just casually hooking up
have you ever thought about that before
I haven't in that context now if I'm
being completely honest that's okay you
can you know you're able to change your
mind on the Pod if if you if you are
convinced sorry Auntie go ahead I was
gonna say when it comes to stabbing
condoms that's what you have to carry
around
you carry it on you open your and you
put it on yourself then you know don't
trust no man and no man should trust no
woman always make sure you see them open
up the packet or you open up the packet
yourself
sure
and what about um abortion so like women
have the choice to get an abortion and
men don't so if you're a single mother
or you have an unplanned pregnancy you
could end it if you wanted to where men
can't
so because of that would you then put
more of the responsibility on the women
yeah why would it not contact okay what
what percent would you give men
um I'd say it's probably in based on
everything that you just said I'd say
it's maybe actually like more 70 women's
responsibility than men okay 70 percent
80 percent
Auntie what do you think
I think that other than the exception
stand to the woman for unplanned
pregnancy once it's unplanned and you
get pregnant and once the man knows that
you sits you don't want no kids
then I think it's down to the woman and
I think that she should hold all
responsibility I don't think she can ask
them man for a penny yeah not in that
situation I agree I think once the man
hasn't said I want a child or he's told
you that I don't want a child and the
woman gets pregnant I got pregnant on
the pill and I feel the same way I think
he's down to the woman your child you
look after it because at the end of the
day you don't have to keep it and if you
decide to keep it in a man don't want it
you look after it
you choose to have it so you have it
because if you didn't want it you would
choose not to have it and if a man
didn't want it then
if you was pregnant and you didn't want
to have the child and your man said I
want you to have the job he's got no
choice in the matter so once you want
all the choice do you have to charge you
have all the choice whoever's got the
child have the choice if you don't want
to make that choice have the children
give it over to the father
this is my view
do you think certain women are proud to
be [__] yes
um why do you think that is
um like I said before I think certain
women find it they they find it a form
of empowerment to say that they can do
what they want with who they want as
many times as they want for their
Messiah breaking them breaking the mold
essentially I think some women will find
it as are they aware usually of how men
feel about it yeah I think they are so I
think is quite known how men feel
towards women that are more promiscuous
than others and do you think men should
feel bad for them and be empathetic
towards them if they become born again
later
no not necessarily I mean
if everyone has their own preference
that you can't force someone to want to
be with someone who has had sex with
loads of people if it's their opinion
like no I don't like that it's not for
me that's perfectly fine you're born
again horse you get a born again pimp
they've got to be around there somewhere
um okay go ahead
do you think some women are proud to be
[__] yeah definitely and why do you
think that is I don't know they just
they're just very open about it so
they don't really have no shame against
it so they just they are who they are
and do you think they're aware of how
men generally feel about it yeah they
are aware but I don't think they care
they just don't care they honestly don't
and you do you think later if they they
do the you know the type the born again
I got three different baby daddies and
now I'm in the church you you know the
time you know she's laughing you know
the time you're thinking to someone
she's thinking I didn't say you I'm just
joking
um do you think men should believe it
and feel bad for them later no I feel
like they should believe it because at
any moment you can change but I mean at
the end of the day
you put an image of yourself out there
so it's kind of hard for others to kind
of accept this new change of yours
especially for men so
yeah but I still feel like at the end of
the day mention except that because
anyone can change do you know any [__]
that have genuinely changed uh I'm not
really so you don't know any but you
think it's possible but I do think it's
possible yeah
do you think it's likely
yeah you think it's likely but you don't
know any I don't know anybody do you
think it's likely
okay
so then why why would a guy believe it
if if you don't know any yeah but just
because I don't know any doesn't mean
this other there are no other woman's
out there that one I mean unicorns exist
but they could be out there yeah but
that's supposed to be this is like we've
like I've I don't necessarily know any
but I believe that there are women out
there that will definitely change okay
what about you
um I don't think any woman's proud to be
a [__] I think that it's a fake facade
that she's putting on and a delusion
um usually women that are [__] they're
usually Intoxicated by something bless
them or they're distracted so I'm saying
that Amber's talking about money money
is a distraction because when you're by
yourself
naked in the mirror or talking to your
psychiatrist you're not proud of how
you're feeling no woman feels good being
with multiple men every woman and every
guy realistically would like to find
that person that they can connect with
so I'm saying like the more guys that
you sleep with it just it's chipping at
you your soul your body everything so
for you to say that you're proud of that
you're lying you're lying to yourself
you're lying to society and everybody
knows it
society makes them proud
that's what I think and they they get
fooled by the guys because look at all
the videos all the the the rap videos
all the videos and you see the ton of
girls in there it's popular so why
wouldn't they want to be a [__] and if
they want to sleep with that guy at the
end of the day they don't mind because
they get somewhere
and I think they're proud to be yours I
think they're getting money for it
they're getting Fame now it's all about
getting money quick and getting Fame
quick best way for a woman to get money
quicker to take her clothes off or look
half naked
have you got a nice Twerk It Jiggle your
breasts around and you've got it made
nowadays you'd be there everyone thinks
they're in a movie in a music video
basically that's the culture
yeah
get rich quick so yeah
people are proud to be yours it's only
when they get old and they realize that
the world's sold them a lie but that
time they are washed up and nobody
really wants them for anything
um
do you think women in general care what
men want
yeah they do
what do you think yeah what do you think
oh I don't think the modern day woman
does I think when you find that woman
that's a little bit more mature and
still a bit cultured
um yeah we do care what I mean our men
want but the Modern Woman no they don't
care what do you think I think women
don't give a [__] till they get older
than lonely they really want a man then
they decide to investigate and find out
what a man wants I don't think they care
so what what do men want
um I'll as in a relationships that's set
in then let's say a wife she's looking
for a wife what does he want in a wife
what does he want her to do what does he
want her to act like he wants it to be a
nurturer he wants it to look after house
and home he wants to look after him
um
and he wants yeah that's I think that's
what men want in a woman which is what
her job should be is which is to not try
and look after the Homemaker house at
home for a man
how would she make a house a home what
are some examples cooking and cleaning
and
um it's women that women it's a women's
touch to a house that makes it homely
um
unless you're Jennifer Pearl we're a
wreck it
um so can I have some specific examples
like because I always hear that make a
house and do a home like how
specifically would you make a house into
a home
um I think it's just little things that
men don't think of like and like the
organization standard like a lot of men
you go into their home it's just very
basic like women will add accents like
candles and cushions and blankets and
yeah but it makes dust collectors it
makes it feel more homely than it does
than just like a shell or something
okay
um can you name something that she
didn't say that you think men want
definitely like taking care of the
children as well
um
basically all the things you said is
what I would agree with but yeah the one
thing she did was taking care of the
children
um definitely makes it at home okay
what about you um I think nowadays men
are looking for like a partner so
someone that they can have like an
honest
um conversation with about work maybe
business ideas their feelings someone
that just kind of understands them and
doesn't judge them too much
do you think that's what men want one
thing yeah I think they want a lot more
obviously I want I think they want
someone open sexually
um someone that's loyal funny
um clean yeah I think on all rounds are
everything you listed sounded like what
women want from men yeah because we both
want them same from each other now what
do you say what do you think
um I think one thing that you didn't no
one mentioned is fit fit yeah like BMI
skinny small tiny yeah but so maybe with
a bite but a small one they don't have a
choice I think they just want a whole
They Don't Really Care what's around the
whole I mean I think it depends like if
a guy has a Jew okay does Leonardo
DiCaprio
date fat chicks or thin chicks do NBA
that's like average guys I know but
that's what I'm saying when when the men
have all the choices in the world it's
like the most beautiful women in the
world who do they date the rich men yeah
right the the most handsome tall
successful men in the world who did they
date the models that's because society
makes it known that that's what is
attractive and that's what's known to be
it's the fact that they that's more
attractive people are respected more by
people because that's that's the
standard that's been set but if that was
the case you wouldn't get big women that
get married if if that's all men want is
a skinny person essentially
um well I mean there's always going to
be someone like I mean one out of three
men are having sex with anyone so
there's always going to be there's
always going to be someone but again I
think you can really see what men want
and like what do they do when the men
that have all the choice who do they
pick
yeah because that's that's the standard
look at George Michael when before he
came out as gay he was seen with models
because it wasn't known to be so what's
your I'm just kidding what's your
premise your premise is that they're
dating them because they're dating the
pretty models because society's telling
them they yeah they could have an
underlying fetish for someone but
they're not going to come out and do
that because Society doesn't deem that's
the type of person that you should be
with as a successful person no I I don't
think so I think like because I mean
being overweight that says something
about you you know it's like it's your
lifestyle choices so if you're in shape
why would you want to date someone
that's not because some people have have
uh have things for people that are of
different right but then but then when
they have the choice to date a fat chick
or a thin chick and they pick the thin
chick
wouldn't that indicate that men like
beautiful thin models yeah but it also
goes back to my point of that's what's
picked as a whole was don't get me wrong
some people do like that that type of
body type however Society deems that
that's the type of person that's known
that you should be with because of your
stature and calibar that doesn't mean
that that you some people will find
other body shapes attractive however
when you're in the Limelight if it were
to be of a bigger girl they're going to
get stick for it because why are you
with the fat chick how essentially how
does society shame that when we have
movements like body positivity for women
and not for as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible